I nice key methods out about the rise of
Skywalker which I saw at the midnight
premiere yeah I'm probably gonna like
delete this video from the channel or
move it to my second channel but for the
moment if I don't get it out now that
I'm never going to get it out at all
I've got the page of notes and I'm just
gonna talk about my confused feelings
there will be spoilers in this video I'm
not gonna hold back I'm just gonna talk
about anything and everything so the
rise of Skywalker if you've seen it let
me know what you thought down below but
the first thing that stood out to me
like unequivocally was that the whole
film felt like a response to the
criticisms of the last Jedi like you
know ray didn't get enough training to
become powerful Jedi so the film opens
with a training montage and with Leia
being her force mentor now she even
first whereas master it sort of felt
like they wanted to do more with that
but they didn't have the time so they
just sort of shoved it in there to go
hey there's there's more stuff here
there's more stuff behind the scenes
where this is going on she's got
training it's just got she's got a
mentor but obviously they didn't do that
much with it so they just sort of shoved
that in there to say that oh you know
she is training that the second thing
the last year I was criticized for is Oh
Luke didn't do anything he was a nobody
he wasn't Luke but then in this film he
learned he's been on like adventures
look looking Forsyth hideouts and stuff
in the past because she's got all of his
books from when he was you know on on
the island or some of his books and so
he went to find the Seth way
marker or whatever was called and yeah I
found that kind of interesting now like
with you or not you like the last Jedi I
have interesting thoughts on it but you
know another one was Rey was a nobody
you know he liked kylo explicitly says
you know your parents were a nobody that
nobody in a sort of a response to that
everyone in Star Wars is connected to
one another everyone's part of the same
family but
then in this film well we're back in it
she is a somebody she's a Palpatine and
I dislike that as a concept necessarily
but it felt like a retcon of the last
Jedi like they even explicitly have this
kind of weird side scene where we see
that layer had a lightsaber and used it
and that's why she had force powers in
the fossil and in the last Jedi that's
why she could do the space thing because
she's a she's a false person she's super
powerful which wasn't really built up to
or anything like that it sort of felt
like it was justifying after the fact
things that happened in the previous
film so fundamentally it felt like a
retcon of the last Jedi which I'm not a
fan of Rick conning I don't think that
even if you sort of miss depth you
should really go back and read Khan or
try to justify like just fight like that
it felt like a continuation thematically
tonally characteristically of the force
awakens and not of the last Jedi and
when you've got basically a whole
chapter of your story that you feel you
can sort of remove and then just wedge
the bits on the other side in between it
comes across is this really disjointed
story so what they're almost doing is is
they're actually making the last Jedi
more redundant than it needed to be and
I'm not necessarily sure that putting
these things in actually still just like
still address the deeper problems with
the narrative so far now III don't think
that like Rey is a MarySue necessarily
but the fact that she had a training
montage like I was watching throughout
the film and I was looking for okay
she's criticized for getting everything
first try and always being able to do
stuff and now there's the justification
of she's the Palpatine she's literally
one of the most powerful force users
ever but she still never fails basically
the only time I was looking out for it
it was at the style of film and she's
fighting the little laser ball that Luke
doesn't she gets shot in the arm and she
gets a little bit angry
and that's sort of a callback to Luke
being you know her struggling with that
at the same time but in all of the
encounters that she has when she fights
coloring on the desert when she's you
know going up against the snake when
she's trying to rescue Chewie when she's
you know even when she's up against
Palpatine
she never has any real miserable failure
she never has any point where she's sit
back probably because of a flaw that she
has in her character that never happened
she pretty much cheat sheets she did
manage to kind of overcome most
obstacles presented to her in the
narrative with relative ease and then
there's a problem because you know I
mean you might say that a floor of her
characters that she's in she's attracted
to the dark side but I didn't feel she
ever really was and whenever we get to a
point of oh she's at Richard that I saw
that she was about to go in and kill the
Emperor and become the Empress we never
really get that that comes from a sense
of hate like it really comes from a
sense of I've got to save my friends
unlike you know compare this to when
Luke is like bashing Darth Vader like
he's won and he's he's beaten Darth
Vader down and then he realizes holy
crap this is what a set does rain never
has a moment where she goes holy crap
I'm doing what a Seth does out of a
sense of anger and misplaced trust and
stuff like that so I yeah that was that
was just interesting now naturally it
would feel like a continuation of the
force awakens because it has JJ Abrams
as the director as opposed to Rian
Johnson and you know they had clearly
conflicting visions of where the Star
Wars
is going to go so that is kind of
natural but as like a narrative arc it
doesn't necessarily work and actually
one of the questions I had the last you
know is that it didn't feel like it was
a continuation of the force awakens it
felt like it took place in a different
Star Wars story one of the things I did
at you like was kylos Redemption arc I
bought kylo being redeemed by the end of
the film aye-aye-aye like he has he is
clearly the best character in the in the
series um he's more complex and layered
and I'm really convinced by his
performance even though you know like he
hasn't given that many lines but he has
a presence on screen that isn't like the
dominant dark prisons of Darth Vader or
the Emperor it's something more complex
and you definitely get the sense that
there's a light and a dark inside of him
a struggle that we never really get with
Ray and the what they did with their
relationship their force relationship
was really clever the fight scenes with
you know you get there little snippets
between the two of them the swapping
between them and then at the end when
they're like she gives him the
lightsaber through this connection that
they have all very clever all very
interesting that was a nice payoff to
that relationship that they're building
up I was wondering where they were gonna
go with that I would have preferred if
kylo and kylo and and Rey defeated the
impre together pretty much once they got
to the Emperor the it was just like war
you know my puppets now and then by kylo
and it goes find cliff and then Rey and
then she defeats them and yeah and I
would have prefered they did it together
as sort of you know they're finally
coming together to defeat to defeat this
great evil that has been supposed to be
puppeteering at all the time so if I
look really tired and I sound really
tightens cuz I literally just woke up if
I have other work to do
and this kind of goes into a deeper
problem which was that the film had a
real sense of contrived tension like all
of a lot of the major obstacles in the
story just sort of came out of nowhere
or you're you're left feeling what why
why is that what what the problem is
like that the start
it's a visually stunning scene you know
with these flashes and pelting look it's
convincing and the set pieces it's
beautiful it's a lovely opening scene
and then suddenly there's this fleet
that arises from the planet of hundreds
of ships with dips Starck you know power
levels of destroying planets how why
where did these come from
and I mean it looks amazing but III mean
with were these ships manned and with
the wind did the first daughter get them
you know like the whole story feels like
it takes place over a couple of days did
the first daughter come to the planet
and then man at all because obviously
they're manned at the end of the at the
end of the movie I didn't I just like
did the empire have these of these lift
over starter stories from the original
Empire and if they aren't then you know
like they they all have planet killing
properties why didn't the Empire use
those I just I just didn't get it the
film even seems to recognize this
contrived tension of points there's a
moment where I think it's thin no Poe is
is fixing a speeder and then post just
like how do you know how to do that
because it's like not establish that you
should be able to do that and there were
a lot of other things like oh all of
these rising ships they need to this
control tower to do it or they won't be
able to we need to blow that up and I I
mean I just like okay so they're just
creating a weird obstacle there
I mean it sort of echoes you know oh
we've got to destroy this port and the
Death Star but it felt odd I don't quite
know how to describe it
Palpatine has all of the Seth inside him
it sort of ramps up this tension of
trying to convince us that Rey killing
Palpatine is going to bring all of the
sift into her and there's like no
precedent for that one thing that one
thing that was cool was actually quite
light at the healing I know that's gonna
be a controversial thing but that there
is force healing and the story first
with the snake sickened with kylo and
thirdly with bringing Rey back from the
dead and it's a callback to you know
Darth Plagueis the wise the ability to
manipulate mere chlorines and he
couldn't save himself but he could save
others and I liked that I thought that
was really well done
they gave it gave this idea that you
know darkside powers can be used for
good which leads into you know her
eventual revelation that she was a great
Jedi kind of I mean it's it's not
explicit it's implicit because she picks
up a golden light saber rather than like
a green or blue one but she's discarding
both red and blue and green which sort
of says that we're discarding that the
dichotomy of the steth and the Jedi so
yeah I like some healing I thought that
was good they set it up
they didn't just come out of nowhere the
first time was used it was used
relatively inconsequential II um but
once again when we returned to kind of
like oh she's a Palpatine that's where
she's got southbounds we run into this
issue of thematically being at odds with
the last Jedi so the last to die was
very much about forget the past it's
behind us we will make our own destiny
come with me you know your parents were
nobody right and in this in this film
obviously she is someone so it's sort of
going past that insane
oh yeah no don't worry Star Wars is
still all about those family bloodlines
but then Luke very explicitly says that
our blood is only one thing and while I
kind of like that they you know they
they brought it back to you know it's
who you choose to be I think I'm not
sure making her a Palpatine would have
would have really made that more
interesting but I don't know my thoughts
on it yet but it feels like they're
trying to kind of work to visions Rian
Johnson's and JJ Abrams into one another
and I don't think that it was planned
all along necessarily for raid to be a
Palpatine there weren't like any strong
hints of it in the previous two films
but the the tension in the film is
ultimately derived from Palpatine being
a threat to supposedly and I'm not sure
that was the best decision it would have
been far more interesting to make the
first order themselves the ultimate
threat and that's what I thought that we
going to do because at the beginning of
the film they introduced this character
called general pride who is kind of a
Tarkin misc character he seems to have a
presence he seems to be able to talk
back but then suddenly they just sort of
cut him off at the legs
general Hux is there as well and what's
really interesting is that they make him
a spy they make him turn and there's
this moment where he says you know I
don't care if you win
I just want kylo Ren to lose and that's
kind of an interesting thing to do with
the character and we see there's a
growing tension between you know the
first order and the the Knights of Ren
and kylo Ren and I thought that we're
gonna build that out until eventually
the first order sort of betrays him
especially as he's sort of like
teetering on between the light and the
good and
and quite know what to do and they
didn't do that instead like the moment
that general Hux became even slightly
interesting as a character beyond just
kind of being a joke they killed him
literally he was a spy and then in there
shot him in the chest
general pride turnaround shaman chest
which was a fine move for general pride
but then general pride wasn't made any
much of a threat either gen pride was
basically just a glorified stand in
character for Huck's once he was gone
and he was just slightly more
intimidating but they didn't do anything
with that and that was annoying it felt
like the first order was just there to
create goons for the bad side rather
than being a real threat themselves when
they the potential to be that you didn't
really need Palpatine to have that kind
of side of tension they could have
developed Huck they could have developed
pride as a more formidable character who
led the charge against kylo Ren and then
we've got kind of this interesting
three-way dynamic between Rey kylo and
general pride with general Hux kind of
thrown in the middle there and he'd have
a great moment at the end so yeah I was
kind of looking looking for that but it
just didn't happen it just never came to
any eventualities at all and I do want
to say that the whole film is shot
beautifully like it has so many moments
where looks amazing and you really feel
like this is a unique location and Star
Wars has always been really really good
at that I especially liked you know the
Fallen Death Star world I think it was
Endor I don't really know also like this
this icy floating ice burg spaceship
right at the spaceport and right at the
start and you know yeah it all looked
really really beautiful EXA chol was
also stunning even though we didn't get
to see much of it but I had this
and deep dark ancient feel to it I loved
it but yeah none of these fix the deeper
problems with the story and so we've
talked about how the tension just wasn't
as good as it could have been or felt in
tribes but let's talk about the emotion
like the emotional sense the things
didn't mean to make us cry and feel and
the one that stood out to me was c-3po
having his memory wiped
now this should have been one of the
most emotional scenes in Star Wars but
they didn't do anything with it even as
this moment where he says some heck
taking one last look at my friend that's
and then the next moment there's just
this kind of joke as he goes dude then
they give him his memory back it felt
like a thing that they could have done
so much more with and I didn't feel
anything even in the way that they did
it even if they brought his memory back
they could have made that initial moment
a lot more meaningful and they didn't so
that kind of sucks I think the emotional
moments between Rey and kylo worked
pretty well I think Kyler's mask you
know with a shattered red looked pretty
damn cool the choreography though for
the fight scenes was bad like wow they
were not immersive they were slow and
they were laborious and it looked like
it looks like when you know actors are
like swinging to hit each other's blades
and not each other so they're going okay
we're gonna go over here then we're
gonna go over here over here I was
waiting for a lot more fast paced
lightsaber battles a lot more
interesting lightsaber battles and they
did that's another thing that they sort
of fellow they were addressing the
criticisms of the last Jedi there are no
lightsaber metal so now there's like six
of them none of them did anything dead
interesting
the fight scene up above really see so
this is over above exa courses with all
the style stories and all the rebellion
arrives
once the rebellion arrives we don't
really get any sense of what's going on
up there you know it's very common for
Star Wars films or just you know sci-fi
fantasy films particular to have the
main character off somewhere and in
there learning that Oh your friends are
dying and then you get a slow motion
music play out of thin Rosen fen trying
to like blow up this tower thing but I'm
not sure that was enough like I wanted
to see I wanted to be following someone
in a spaceship and have them trying to
do something but not being able to and
then eventually managing to you know
having their own arc throughout this
battle instead of just seeing snippets
of it where things are happening so
that's kind of my feelings on the rise
of Skywalker I know it's been a ramble
but yeah it was just not as good as it
could have been I feel like they could
have done it a lot more simply with just
kind of a triangle between first-order
Keio and Rey and developed villains in
the first order so where does the first
order get it some money from like the
Empire was a governing body and I don't
think the first order is a governing
body at least it's not clear that it is
they seem more like a very very
expensive terrorist organization like I
enjoyed it in the moment and you know
that's fine that is a good bar to hit
for a film and all it's good which a lot
of films don't but I came away with it
with just a feeling of unsatisfaction
like this should have been more and for
a movie with I don't know I'm gonna
guess three hundred million dollars
thrown at it
I was hoping for that but yeah anyways
I'm probably going to delete this video
for my channel move it to my second
channel to the future cuz just around
but let me know your thoughts down below
Merry Christmas because this will
possibly be my last video of the year
and stay nerdy and I'll see you in the
future